j'ai eu l'idée du siècle encore on
emploie des gens qui vont porter les
chaussures de nos clients tu connais
déjà complété
par est ce que je pourrais avoir un
petit jus de goyave et après avec mon
petit point de
vue original
est un peu compliqué pour toi t'as vu la
vie qu'ils mènent faut que je redonne le
sont
aussi les cartes de crédit sont bloqués
il comprend talent aussi
la plus d'argent ils veulent nous [ __ ]
en prison pardon
non épaissi moi ou pas d'un champ paston
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et merci artus date avec moi je suis
très heureux dow et c'est vrai qu'on
s'est tous posé la question papa moi
mais vous je sais que vous atteindrez
extrêmement fortunée autour de la table
c'est vrai pour vos enfants mais on
s'est tous posé la question et gérard
moi c'est ça que j'aime bien dans le
sujet du film parce que j'étais que par
exemple vous benhaim vous gâter votre
fils qui a maintenant 56 ans et c'est
vrai qu'il est gâté pourri non mais
c'est vrai que c'est quand on rit à neuf
et m'ont dit on se dit que c'est vrai
qu'il ya ça questionne ouais ça
questionne oui mais c'est compliqué
parce que c'est moi être un petit peu
d'argent
mais c'est bouger mais ces bijoux sur
les fringues à mama
c'est vraiment
bien pour les ranger la direccte sur les
rails vous n'avez pas habiter dans une
chambre de bonne et faire manger des
pâtes à vos membres a pas tout le temps
ici où c'est ce que vous ferez pas envie
que l'on parle
dernier et on puisse quand même quoi il
est bien née ton fils quand même
dans le poème c'est pas ça le problème
il est de bien sûr qu'il faut capter des
fonds pour rire c'est ça
c'est vrai c'est ce que vous avez fait
vous dire à moi je dépôts et ses rennes
non franchement il y aura me souvenais
il n'est pas pourri gâté du tout c'est
un beau soleil mme formidable c'est un
bosseur qu'arthur ouais ça danse que
c'est pas du son fils arthur salach y
avoir c'est alors moi bon elle paye
c'est vrai que par moments
c'est un bosseur arthur jugnot c'est un
bosseur il non mais c'est vrai c'est un
mec exceptionnel donc c'est vrai que les
packs gâte voulait peut-être gâtés mais
pas pour ie9 est aujourd'hui c'est que
toutes les satisfactions qui pourrait
avoir dans la vie c'est lui qui se les
procurent disant c'est pas parce qu'il
est fils de ou qu'il a il méritait
peut-être un jour je ne suis pas sûr de
mourir j'ai pendant tout le temps n'est
pas en tout cas on n'est pas pour
préparer mon tir haut on n'est pas pour
alors vous avez vu le film autour des
tables qu'est ce que vous en dépensez
artus exceptionnel artus mais tous les
connu certes sonné et dominique farrugia
qui connaît bien gérard on est
complètement fan de toi on parle tout le
temps toi c'est gentil j'arrive beaucoup
de minutes mais voilà je salue mille
projets qu'il se sait jamais fait
ensemble ils vont se faire un look et
chaque fois kim au téléphone il me parle
de toi alors je ne sais pas si vous avez
un truc tous les deux même à une
relation une fois
une morphologie maintenant il va
beaucoup minci et en tout cas on
n'embrasse pas dominant et ben
moi j'ai adoré le film j'ai trouvé ça
super drôle super temps très touchant
moi c'est vrai qu'en tant que mère je me
suis projeté c'est à dire que je me suis
dit est-ce qu'il faut dire la vérité à
ces enfants là il faut leur mentir pour
justement bien les éduquer et voilà je
trouve que le film est très réussie
alors vos trois enfants ils sont géniaux
moi j'étais au top tout mais aussi
c'était de réflexion at home il excella
dort
jamais
et je trouve bien jouer au tennis un peu
s'arrête
toujours
moins lotis les beaux ils vont
non seulement il est rigolo c'est une
machine à colombes mais en plus tu as
très bons acteurs et la route dans le
film des touches engagement c'est un
traître un entre sk sergine qui fait du
bien ça fait une drôle mais pas que
c'est ça ça me plaît le côté un peu en
fait on se ressource la question quand
on voit le film original et vu j'ai
adoré et je trouve que en lisant vos
interviews là où vous êtes excellence et
que ça vous rappelle votre propre
histoire à vous vous parlez de votre
père vous parlez de votre fils et on a
l'impression que vous revivez avec plein
d'émotion que vous nous fait partager
tout ce que vous avez vécu vous-même
donc c'est drôle c'est touchant ça
interroge ça questionne ses brillants
j'ai adoré franchement c'est un morceau
d'anthologie
elle a bien fait de venir
de même quand tu aimes un film on al
impression qu énervé mais ce travail au
port au parisien
pourquoi ne pas y met le panier je suis
pas je crois pas bon ok c'est trop
populaire est trop de qualités
j'ai quelques comptes à régler mais
[Rires]
ça va être l'heure je n'ai pas beaucoup
l'eau c'est un film grand public
qui à tous les publics et moi c'est ce
qu'on essaye de faire dans mes films ou
danseuse dans lequel je tourne des
scènes d'être dans le plus large
possible et dans des films d'auteur
grand public jusqu'au
artus artus sa carrière justement car
tous il peut être très bien sur des
trucs très pointu doit être grand public
c'est pour ça que j'aime beaucoup artus
aussi ce qu'il est populaire il est
populaire dans le bon sens du terme il
peut faire des choses très pointu mais
il reste toujours grand public c'est
celui remarqué non mais c'est vrai
c'est un truc qui compte pour toi tu as
envie voilà de tunis i c'est important
pour moi de ne pas louer mais tu as
envie tu as envie de casser un peu les
15 qu'on a tendance à l'amont les
premiers rôles qu'on me propose et c'est
un peu toujours le gros de service ils
n'ont pas envie de chiba au départ j'ai
la grosse non et puis là c'est cool
parce que d'après le bureau à
je démarre un film il se passe en 1900
il s'appelle
avec
et du coup s écoule de montrer qu'on
peut on peut faire un peu tout et parce
que sinon c'est chiant quand on fait de
tout le temps le même rôle est grosse
mais ce qui est bien aussi c'est pas
dire c'est mieux le bureau des légendes
que c'est non non
c'est comme en télé en foot à sa place
c'est vrai c'est que ces commentaires
c'est d'ailleurs le théâtre ce n'est pas
ceci et cela c'est ceci et cela l'a pas
ceci ou cela c'est ceci lui tout cela ça
tu
étais heureux du jura oui mais je
connaissais pas ouais mais les mêmes
même pas
d'inquiéter la personne non mais
évidemment c'est ce fait partie des gens
voilà la troupe disparue tout équipé
avec qui tu rêves de jeu enfin tu
l'imaginés même pas moi j'ai imaginé pas
il ya et quelques années pouvoir jouer
avec jean et puis en plus on il s'est
passé quelque chose oui on est une
petite relation elodie à la fabrique
s'est bien marré non mais ce qui est
intéressant point c'est que c'est pas ma
base et un peu vite chaud
mais c'est un peu humiliant là avant
tout le monde a fait ça un peu vite mais
c'est non mais ce qui est bien c'est que
moi j'ai pas l'euro le comics qui
faisait sarine ouais c'est vrai moi j'ai
un rôle de clown blanc et ça c'est très
agréable matière tue c'est un très beau
sourire bah oui
c'est le spécialiste cinéma le
spécialiste médias qui parlent des mots
ces deux spécialistes de qq
c'est très important un très beau
sourire ah oui c'est vrai et il dégage
quelque chose de formidable c'étaient
les abdos ou le sourire
mais c'est un film effectivement sur le
pont sur la transmission la question qui
est posée c'est la transmission
qu'est-ce qu'on transmet à ses enfants
mais je me connais ça
j'ai eu quelques règles de la vie quoi
des toits de toujours avoir de
l'empathie pour l'autre est d'essayer
d'être heureux le chien aboie
mais
dans la vie tous les plaisirs qu'on a il
faut il faut quand même se sortir les
doigts du c est un effort
travailler même si on est passionné il
ya de l'effort mais ça il faut sortir de
l'amour c'est fatigant le monsieur bien
sûr mais c'est vraiment une année sortir
les doigts du cul
[Rires]
transmettre à vos enfants et
pour avancer il faut écraser l'autre
voilà
[Applaudissements]
erreur de place sur marie ah oui
mais il faut s'excuser après
qu'est-ce que vous
nicolas pernikoff le respect
alors la plus inquiète
les trucs hyper serré on est dans un
monde où les gens se respectent de moins
en moins respect c'est vachement
important une valeur pour les enfants
non
[Applaudissements]
les pct miss ile-de-france
[Rires]
à la bienveillance voila voila
moi si j'en avais et quand je vais en
avoir ce serait de qui fait la vie qui
fait là dit ouais parce qu'on se met des
influences mais des trucs on sera des
machins chaque moment chaque truc car
peu de soi simple compliqué qui flavie
évidemment prendre la drogue
et tout ce que tu veux tiens et mettrait
jamais
ne jamais tenir compte de l'opinion des
autres ah ouais bah vous êtes vous au
niveau de la coiffure
c'est sa voix ça quand on est vrai débat
bravo vous à moi mon fils que je peux la
minute est quoi acheter les minitels
sais pas si
mon fils qui se marient dans 15 jours je
lui laisserai le sens de l'effort de
chat et un comportement c'est déjà pas
mal on parle des valeurs pas les bras
leur poids de l'héritage
vous allez laisser en héritage à nos
enfants même le pôle récit se démerde
bernard montiel vous la récompense du
travail bien fait ah bon alors c'est pas
du tout ça et
surtout pas faire comme moi depuis 40
cents à la télé en revanche c'est ce que
prône d'ailleurs ce sont les valeurs du
film c'est ça c'est ça ça de travail
récompensé le bonheur de travailler
aussi quoi qu'il en soit il est venu
prononcer bien sûr j'ai reçu gérard hier
à rfm de la vub donc pour athènes pour
touche peut être
placé parue aujourd'hui non j'ai pas eu
le temps mais on va voir pour te paie
bah oui c'est ça
vous l'avez dit on a parlé une bonne
petite heure on a parlé de beaucoup de
choses on a évoqué plein de choses
sur le film j'ai dit que c'était une
très belle comédie évidemment j'ai dis
bravo à tous les interprètes du film
gérard justement il est le rôle des
augustes est différent comment on peut
avoir un fou rire aussi long sur
l a pas de sol y'a pas de son qui sort
elle rigole
c'est bloqué à 12 ans
alors ayez donc ouais donc je disais que
c'était non seulement une belle comédie
justement girard l'a précisé tout à
l'heure et là le rôle d'auguste
t'écoute même pas ce que disaient aussi
j'ai inversé
et étudier tout le week end a cramé non
mais c'est vrai après tout cas c'est une
bd qui est bien agréable à regarder
jugez vous vos envois ma fille j'ai
l'honnêteté l'intégrité et puis
peut-être jamais se prendre au sérieux
mais alors vous en les choses
sérieusement j'aurais peut être votre
fils
il a un peu de ressemblance c'est
vraiment ça me plairait bien le relm
avoir un fils c'est vrai ouais bah
écoutez le mien très plaisir vous le bon
goût et l'amour de la mode
oui mais c'est à bord et ont le bon goût
et l'amour de la mode écoutez sa porte
la durée de ses mentors
le chef de choeur pourtant que vous
allez transmettre à vos enfants l'argent
ça dépend comme on gagne ouais c'est
vrai et l'argent récompense il ya
l'argent
comptant pour la botte éco responsables
se seraient les vrais bien sûr comme
c'est important c'est important j'ai
adoré le film moi c'est vrai mario
batali pomme non médecin très présent
tout en vidant plein mais en fait c'est
une comédie populaire mais c'est un
sujet intelligent parce que c'est vrai
les enfants pourris gâtés il ya plein de
gens qui tombent dessus alors ceni de la
faute des parents qu'ils ont le droit
d'avoir du succès et les enfants mais
ils ont le droit d'exister donc c'est un
peu dur d'élever ses enfants quand on
est une immense fortune j'imagine comme
c'est le cas de votre personnage sera
très bon sujet voilà cela veut dire
parce que ce qui leur donne une leçon
mais qui l'empruntent